حذر الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش من احتمال امتداد الصراع في
السودان الى المنطقه وقال غوتيريج خلال
جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس الامن الدولي انه يجب
على المجتمع الدولي ان يبذل جهدا شاملا من
اجل السلام ودعترفي النزاع الى اسكات
البنادق
على السلطه في السودان لا يعرض مستقبل هذا
البلد للخطر فحسب بل انه يشعل فتيلا يمكن
ان ينفجر عبر الحدود ايضا ويسبب عاناتا
هائله لسنوات ويعيد التنميه عقودا الى
الوراء يجب ان يتوقف القتال على الفور نحن
بحاجه الى جهد شامل من اجل السلام وادعو
اطراف النزاع الجنرالين عبد الفتاح
البرهان ومحمد حمدان حميدتي والقوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع الى
اخراج المناطق
واكد غوتيريش انه لن يتم حل الصراع في
ميدان المعركه ودعا السودانيين الى وضع
مصالح الشعبهم في المقدمه
على القاده السودانيين ان يجعلوا مصالح
شعبهم قبل كل شيء اخر هذا الصراع لن يحل
ولا يجب ان يحل في ميدان المعركه بجثث
الشعب لقد عبر الشعب السوداني عن تطلعاته
بوضوح شديد انه يريد السلام واستعاده حكم
المدني من خلال الانتقال الى الديمقراطيه